a coronavirus model used by the White
House now projects more than 200,000
Americans could die of kovat 19 by
october 1st that's up more than 30,000
since last week this morning the
official US death toll exceeds 100
16,000 and is still growing by several
hundred per day Manuel Bojorquez is in
Miami Manuel Florida is one of several
states where infections are on the rise
what's the government saying about that
well Anthony on a call with the nation's
governor's Monday vice president Mike
Pence urged state leaders to attribute
the spike in new cases to quote the
magnitude of the increase in testing but
without providing clear evidence that's
the only explanation other key metrics
like hospitalizations are also on the
rise in several states some leaders here
in Miami say they are not taking any
chances now is not a time to let your
guard down Miami mayor Francis Suarez
put the next phase of his city's
reopening on hold we are seeing an
uptick particularly in the age
demographic 18 to 35 and particularly
after Memorial Day weekend statewide
about 12,000 Floridians have tested
positive over the last seven days
June Ellis works for one of the state's
largest public health systems what is
the situation like at Jackson Health
right now we have started to see an
increase again in our positive patients
since June first hospitalizations have
risen in at least 11 states including
Texas which reported more than 2,300
hospitalizations a record high for the
seventh time in eight days and 20 states
reported increases in their average new
kovat 19 cases compared to two weeks ago
so many people at the White House
President Trump attributed the rise in
cases to an increase in testing that's
probably the downside of having good
testing as you find a lot of cases that
other countries who don't even test
don't have but in several states data
show that's not entirely true
according to professor wave Vega
Oum schneider a computer scientists at
the university of illinois a data comes
directly from john hopkins and it
doesn't do any projection at all even
though we're seeing the same or
sometimes even more testing the number
of positive cases were seeing those
regions is actually increasing at a rate
far exceeding the number of tests
increasing also on Monday the FDA
rescinded its emergency authorization
for the use of the drug
hydroxychloroquine to treat kovat 19 the
president criticized that decision it's
a drug that he had promoted as a
possible treatment for the virus and
actually taken himself the FDA said new
information showed the drug was unlikely
to be effective tony has some big
developments there on multiple fronts
Manny thank you very much